thank you
[Music]
I've been trying to tell y'all Brett
Clayton's coming to Rob your bank
I came to put a bullet
my name is Johnny Black I am no
gentleman and I am no preacher I thought
I would join you for breakfast
Hallelujah fat man is not what he
pretends to be
didn't the Bible say to turn the other
cheek oh no I mean probably yeah I said
stop stop me but I also said you can hit
a bully with a slingshot and this is
mine
on crack Shot Bob well now you just shot
I think ain't no preacher at all false
prophets Rose Among the people you know
this bile man Reverend family Reverend
famine I'll be Reverend family and
you'll be my Deacon now why in God's
name would I agree to do something like
that like that that's all oil found on
the pound is about to come into a whole
heap of money we must arm ourselves and
prepare for the worst I'd rather die on
my feet to live on my knees
let's go
I say a life worth living is a life
worth defending
foreign
[Music]
that wasn't a complete sentence